[Music]
rob jeff calling from
northern virginia you've recommended
other fantastic books
would really like to know what else you
recommend or can you come out with a
list on your show
of of rob lowe must reads or your top
20.
i really look forward to that um and
again just uh i i cannot tell you what
an experience i had
with the moons of allah thank you so
much for everything well jeff
from northern virginia by the way i love
north that you're from northern virginia
it's like you're in a civil war
battalion i love that
i'm from northern virginia um that's
great um thank you i'm glad you liked
moons of balloon it it's
it it it you know it was my inspiration
for for writing my two books um
so the northern virginia civil war thing
made me think
of one of my favorite books which is
called the killer angels
and it is a book uh i believe it won the
pulitzer prize
and it is sort of the definitive account
of the battle of gettysburg
and you don't have to be a historian or
a civil war buff
to read it nor should you be it's just
the most beautifully
written emotional um
very short books i've ever read so
that's the killer angels
um another one i am loving uh is
um i believe it's called under the
comanche moon
um and i just heard that paul thomas
anderson
one of my favorite directors is has been
secretly working on the movie adaptation
of under the comanche note so that is
going to be one of the great movies of
all
time and there you have it thanks i love
that i need to do like an oprah's book
like recommendation thing oprah i'm
coming for you
this is just the first version of it
look out there's more to come